in the previous video we looked at the
concept of factorial but at the end of
the video i also asked you all to find
out the values of one factorial and zero
factorial did you get the answers
even if you got the answers do you all
know the logic behind your answers
let's see we have an interesting way to
understand this three factorial is six
this basically tells us how we can write
three things in different ways
say the three things are a b and c we
can write it in six different ways
that's three factorial two factorial is
two
say we have a and b then we can write it
in just two ways a b and b a
now one factorial means we have just one
element in our set say a we can write it
in just one way a this means one
factorial is one and zero factorial
means we do not have any element in our
set now this can also be written in just
one way hence zero factorial is equal to
one
before you leave here's another question
for you what is the value of 6 factorial
leave your answers in the comments
section